Ah, see?  Troy's got my back.
Bullshit, he's just afraid to take sides.
No, I'm not.
You should be.
I'd own your ass in a fight.
But why would I fight you?
Yeah, that would be like the most boring fight ever.
Abby would knock you out in two seconds.
(Together) Oh!  Bam!
I think I see it, actually.
I'm not sure what--Ow!
I'm going to toughen you up boy!
OW!
Dude, what the Hell?  Stop!  Stop stop, please!
Oh, guys!  Here it is!
Fuck yes!
Come on, we saw this the other day.
Super cool.
What?  Are you scared?
No, we just...we've never been down this...this path.
Aw, it's going to be okay buddy.
Come on, you can do it.
You guys always say it's fine.  There's not even a trail marker.
You've got to own up to this growth spurt that you had.
How much further?
It's just over that hill.
Maybe two hills.
Three.
No.
What?
No dude, I'm done.  This is a dumb idea.
Dude, stop being such a pussy.
We're just having fun.
We are miles from everything.  We have no cellphone reception.
If one of us gets hurt, we're done.
We have no way to get back.  Do you understand that?
Okay.
We would be stranded.
(Abby) *screams*
Abby!?  Abby!
Hah!  Just kidding!
Hahaha!
See?  That's what I'm talking about.  That's exactly what I'm talking about.
You face is so cute when you get scared.
That stops.  No that stop right now.
Yes sir.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Okay!  That was the last one.
That was the last one, I promise.
Yes, promise.
Here we go, come on.
Okay, okay!  No more.  And you'll come and it will be amazing.
Keep it moving boy!
Left!  Left!  Left, right left!
Know what this is?
It's a Fairy Ring.  It's a place of great sacred power.
That's right.  Ancient Black Magic and shit.
Shut up, I'm telling the story.
Four hundred years ago, children who wandered into these woods
either came out crazy or didn't come back at all.
Those who did come out said that they'd seen
five beautiful witches.
They tried to lure them into the center of the ring for a sacrifice.
Five suspicious townswomen were tried and hung
but it was no use.
Any children that came near these woods *claps* would vanish.
They say if you listen closely,
you can still hear the sound of the witches laughing.
And if you do, you'll never come out alive.
*sounds of witches laughing*
*chuckling*
Oh my goodness!  It doesn't get better than this.
That face!
So priceless!
So good.
Come on witches!  Lets go!
Oh, witches!
Bring it on!
Oh, maybe we should make a sacrifice.
Oh, yeah.  Wouldn't want to insult the witches.
No way.
No no no.
Where are you going?
I don't want to do this.
I don't want to--
*Witches laughing*
Hey guys, this is a bad prank.
I mean, we are way too old for pranks.  This is stupid.
Did your sister's friends do this?
No!
Then who the fuck are these people?
I don't know!
Are you fucking kidding me?  You dragged me down here!
This is--
*Witches laughing*